please work please work I think it's
working
I'm live I was gonna say where I am but
maybe people can guess where I am
oh I should open up the chat let me open
up the chat okay Chad is now open hello
to people who have not yet arrived I'm
gonna play this mysterious dark solid
rectangle tournaments I think this is a
classical arena it's a classical shield
arena there is just under five hours
left it's 20 minutes plus ten second
increments that's actually a reasonable
time control for what I want to do I
might just play one game and then talk
to people or talk about the game and try
and break into the top 1000 it's over
2,100 players playing this playing
wayward waywardness rated 1705 question
mark let's play do I want to play let's
play normal chess forgot I still have
this blindfold tool thing but I'm not
gonna play blindfold even though I could
play blindfold I won't we have a pond
Gianni I used to play this and I teach
this a lot it's such a it's a fun
opening to teach White's plan is very
straightforward to play this move d4 and
now I might go into the tank because I
have so many things I can play against
upon Jionni I mean there's two kind of
main lines there's neither of six and
there's d5 d5 is probably the most
reputable but there's an interesting
line I think I want to go into which
starts with Knight f6
and there's a line I want to play which
some people claim that it just refutes
the pons eonni uh unfortunate my points
not going into it maybe I'll have to
show it afterwards
the line was a d4 Knight takes d5 Bishop
c5 with a piece sacrifice that would
have been really fun but Queen c2 Queen
c2 is a bit seems a bit off but I have
to be careful I'm realizing if I play
Bishop c5 I'm allowing this move so I
should probably calculate Bishop c5
Knight takes e5 Knight takes e5 d4 I
lose buck apiece
so Bishop c5 Knight takes e5 there's
Bishop takes f29 take c5 Bishop takes f2
King takes f2 Knight takes e5 d4 not
sure how great that is for me and I have
Knight FG for King g1 the queen controls
f2 I also have d5 here maybe d5 the way
to go cuz Bishop c5 it's it's inviting
too many tricks with this or this even
like b4 b5 d5 is um I mean much safer it
probably just stronger too and this will
facilitate developments hello to people
in the chat people are in the chat and
they're saying hello wait Eric were you
here
wait wait Eric where were you earlier
where was I earlier how much earlier
like a few minutes ago or a few hours
ago
or a few days ago oh you're probably
referring to the stream title I yeah
I've been out of the country for how
long was it was tilled y29 through
August 8th so a good 9 to 10 days I was
in Canada I was playing a tournament in
Montreal there was a five-day tournament
and then I stayed a few more days to
enjoy Canada enjoy the food
but poutine the fresh Canadian air chess
broswer in town for a little bit okay d3
so I still want to play this move but
they're still like this thing to worry
about
I don't think it's that strong just I'll
have to calculate I still have to worry
about b4 - I could take and then play
Bishop c5 probably taking this position
a bit too seriously there's a lot of
natural developing moves
I mean a5 is also new a5 discouraging
before I actually attempted to play that
and then we have like a reverse old
Indian let's play that to a5 it's a
weird move feel like it's a type of move
a lot of players would not consider but
it's positional the whites playing kind
of passively so I want to play
restrictive Lee Shabazz Oh from Chicago
red pixel from the Netherlands hope
niggles is back stock versus back in
Budapest at the sigit Festival never
heard of that but I have heard of
Budapest the city and the opening we
have Greece in the house
yeah Montreal was a very nice City Rosen
you go to the gym so you're asking me if
I work out I I joined Orangetheory
which is I think it's considered a gym
it's like a membership workout thing
where you have one hour like
high-intensity group trainings I signed
up for eight classes a month so it's
still new for me I play tennis
I play tennis today I played US Open
tennis
for chess players I still want to play
this move Bishop c5 Knight takes e5
takes d4 I could take on e4 then
actually that looks nice and I went upon
yeah let's play Bishop c5 playing
actively I used a lot of time but okay
this is classical chess you meet chess
for us yeah I saw chess Roz it's hard to
miss him if you go to Canada they're all
over the place h3 let's castle I can't
spend too much time on every move just
have to play quickly and moments that
aren't so critical rook e8 is very
normal
getting my standard setup soaking wet
psy thanks for subbing I'm really far
behind in the chat like I've I'm slowly
scrolling down it's taking a while why
don't I play arena kings events I played
like the majority of arena Kings this
past season I missed a few due to
traveling and also I was playing a
tournament for a week night f1 might
have won seems slow I mean it's typical
white wants to do this Bishop g5 maybe
attack me what to do
I play a four it's a question like how I
actually use my leading development this
f2 seems very tender dreaming of my
queen going to a7 could be an
interesting maneuver to play h6 to stop
Bishop g5 but h6 allows maybe g4 g5 and
there's a smooth which could be
interesting as well
what else to do and pawn b5 Ponzi for
just trying to identify like all the
resources plane IG 7 to g6 I've stopped
looking at the chat by the way I'm
trying to focus on what to do here I
want some plan I got like my position
that it could be better
I mean Bishop e6 is kind of normal this
reminds me of a game I played a year ago
in Romania against GM Mora Ryu who
crushed me he played very slowly in the
opening I played aged 6 to early and
then he destroyed me with g4 g5 dude won
104 thanks for receiving still trying to
stay focused Bishop e6 my g5 kind of
annoys me Knight g5 maybe allow taking
on e6
I mean d4 is also very thematic there's
a game Carlson was black against
Nicholas Rosenthal or they had structure
like this neat just play d4 got some
space advantage d4 c4 I have night
before
I'm sure that leads to much night before
Queen D 1 a for maybe its pleasant
though let's play d4 if pawn takes I
have night before or no I bishop before
and then takes on d4 yeah ok I need a
tissue
I'll be right back BRB ok I'm really
behind in the chat oh man hello from
Maine says grooviest you're making
cocktails you're making cocktails are
you wait are you at the US Open cuz if
you're nearby and maybe I would request
something I'm Marcin nagas from Malaysia
I was there like 9 months ago Malaysia
was very nice country good food
let's take probably or do I play a four
first I mean if I take Queen can't take
what the pawn can take so I feel like I
should try to go for a four eight three
this pin doesn't really annoy me yeah
let's do this
and again if take side Bishop b4 yeah
each six wasn't move I didn't really
want to play on this was a Ponzi Ani
uncle Vinnie from Seattle
welcome oh you're making cocktails in
the Netherlands okay never mind I was
also in Netherlands few times over the
years another nice country so I plays a3
which weakens b3 first move that comes
to mind maybe a couple moves like this
in this also this
if light takes on d4 I still have Bishop
takes d4 a let's play Bishop e6 really
just trying to improve the position with
every move it's hard to open the center
like completely so White's King is safe
but if I keep improving hopefully
someday I'll have tactics I currently
have nothing to drink
but I finished one of those really
unhealthy like Starbucks like latte
sugar caffeine drinks in a glass bottle
so I'll have energy for the next like 45
minutes hopefully occ 1d thanks for
subbing with twitch crime I look old
fashioned does that make me old or does
that make me fashionable
saying boo Starbucks is not acceptable
on the stream I love Starbucks I usually
get like healthier things sometimes it
is hard to get healthy stuff at
Starbucks so so many drinks with so much
sugar c4 I would love to on Toussaint's
if this were just 24 maybe I could on
two sons c4 explosive but closing
everything down I mean in positions like
this I think it's very important to
identify like the potential pawn breaks
for black I think there's two clear ones
there's potentially f5 or b5 I think it
makes sense to go for d5 and the
question is how to best execute it if I
can't really play b5 right away Bishop
on c5 not defended I could start with
rook a5 start with Knight a5 it's
interesting my five looks too exotic
there's a few things I have to do is one
move that comes to mind I kind of like
which is Bishop e7 idea of 97 to c5 a
knight should be on c5 now the bishop
let's play Bishop e7 old fashions are
very fashionable currently okay oh like
an old-fashioned drink ah
they each - what does my opponent trying
to do Knight g4 maybe we're trying to
castle let's go for this well maybe I
would take with night to get this Knight
to f4 in closed positions it's very
important to just see how the Knights
condensed and essentially identify like
best squares for the Knights because
black has time lots of time to maneuver
let's play this night b3 probably coming
at some point still gonna take a few
moves to prepare b5 I might want the
Queen on c5 like 93 I should probably
play it at 6 here just reinforce
everything because this is a targets BAM
w brother bought some stuff from Amazon
just today but what kind of stuff if you
don't regret it that's good though and
if you have Amazon Prime you can get
free shipping and subscribe to me
hey Zeff Reza Ted knows what's up a 6
ban emote that's been Feingold's least
favorite emotes Whateley chest looks
more crisp on my screen wait your leach
s looks more crisp on my screen than we
chests when I play its so you're
watching on twitch when you mean crisp
it's like higher resolution or it's I
mean maybe it could be like a dark theme
versus a light theme I don't know
I had to reduce the bit rate like
substantially because the upload speed
here it's like 2 or 3 megabits per
seconds well does this move my h2 wants
to play off for probably if I play h5
does that just win a night that wins the
night right okay Y could win two pawns
but ok winning a night in the position
like this will feel very nice if you
ever have a position where you thought
you were losing and that your opponent
resigned probably not in a tournament
I've seen premature resignations before
I can't think of any like specific
instance okay I was expecting Knight
takes f6 followed by Bishop takes h5 and
this also is probably playable but okay
I'm winning a piece okay so White's
gonna argue that there's still some
attack which is true these pawns are
somewhat menacing maybe I should take
facilitate some trades opens up a five
square and the bishop can come in yeah
this was my worst bishop when I have
this pawn chain so if it can trade off
I'll be very nice
I don't take with Queen
yeah the center is opening up I'm up a
piece
what about g5 just so you can use the
emotes g5 no no I'm not in the mood to
push pawns in front of my king I mean it
attacks a bishop but I don't know what
it does beyond that it's like Whitewood
retreats and then my pawns can't move
backwards it weakens f6 permanently not
all attacking moves are like good moves
even when it's g5 I'm sure I'll play g5
at some point this game especially if
love hate chess arrives while castling
queenside so now b5 looks enticing maybe
I can look lifted aking ideas might be
for stuff rook a6 to b6 trying to think
I should really start with b5 let's play
b5 okay I don't even win the pawn back
right away but I think the fact that I'm
opening up the diagonal is very valuable
actually yeah if take side Bishop e3
who's just crushing yeah this is my
first classical game on the chess in a
long time I can't remember the last time
I play classical chess I feel like if I
play one game then I'll be on the like
eater board okay I always play king b1
I could take I could push both options
looking very attractive let's push
I mean yeah King bee one kind of invites
a rope to the bee file but like what
else to do the King was gonna be
attacked anyway 93 was coming
if takes Bishop III was coming Queen at
four if necessary so now it's gonna be a
party on the Kings side yeah the the
combination of the Knights the rooks
Queen Queen and bishops still have some
influence I mean if I had to guess like
the final move if I'm like gonna end the
game with mates it could very well be
something like Queen takes a three or
Knight be three mates let's open the
file first yeah if people want to guess
a final checkmating move what will it be
[Music]
yeah Queen jigs a3 is becoming more
realistic at this point I think my
threat is something like Knight takes e4
I have to be a little bit tricky in the
way I do this though so I take on you 40
ticks on b3 hmm how do I do this and
there's an interesting forcing line rook
takes a three which wins
like a boatload of material
so close I think well I'll just play a
quiet move I mean there's so many ways
to just like destroy but I'm gonna play
rook a v8 because if takes and I I just
win the Queen and meanwhile I still want
to move the knight and then have Queen
takes a three yes so let's take on e4 it
also has ideas of this this is not so
easy all right this is just over but I'm
happy that I like a few months ago I
said Queen digs a3 could be the final
move back when it was still questionable
I like the suggestions or the guesses in
the chat Queen a3 Gigi I had rook a 3-2
cuz I've made some other people happy
like snuggler I would have taken less
energy to move the mouse good job red
pixel predicting the future yeah my
opponents played chess I actually
probably a lot of people join the stream
like after the opening but I was
mentioning at the beginning that I was
kind of hoping for this line after d4
takes d5 this is a main line and if
flack were to play 97 which is the most
common move I think it's very playable
for whites and this is what I teach the
students from the white side but there
is a slightly lesser known move here
which is very tricky and there's a lot
of computer preparation that can go into
it Bishop c5
okay white has won a lot of the top
games but if you turn on the engine like
it won't fully understand what's going
on I think it says like approximate
equal but then you have to like dig like
10 to 15 moves deep to try and come to
some conclusion but it's a fascinating
variation where after it takes Bishop
takes up to p2 and then I believe Bishop
b6 as a computer move I mean it this can
be very high-level opening preparation
and I'll admit I don't know too much
beyond this I remember like studying
this several months ago but something
that I I would be terrified to play as
whites and I think this is why this is
probably one of the reasons why kanjyani
like isn't so popular is because of this
line red pixel going to bed good night
probably in Europe somewhere
I assume Oh probably said was in
Netherlands someone is from the
Netherlands
oof is late yeah Netherlands welcome oof
if you're just joining I'm sharing my
opening novelty secrets even though this
is a novelty it's not so well known and
if you're an e5 player as black you
should have some idea what to play
against pawns eonni and can highly
recommend learning this because a lot of
players just won't know Bishop c5 and
things can go south for white very very
quickly
law of HS in the chat I said your name
like a couple minutes ago there's a an
opportunity for me to play g5 in this
position someone suggested g5 but I
didn't play it because you were in here
also it wasn't the best move
so this is going to be a relatively
quick stream